et dans la lune personnes oui une
personne est dans l'oeil du cyclone
cette personne nous l'avons accueilli à
bras ouverts il était sur nrj 12
présentée le mag présentée est tellement
vrai ouais présente est tellement vrai
et parfois le week end il a présenté
tellement vrai et la star ac 1 quand
même merci
il a présenté tellement il a présenté
également ouf parce que cet homme humble
humain mais il aime également l'animal
n'est ce pas jean marc il est le
meilleur
cette personne at elle été appelé par
une autre chaîne
septième au miroir de tourner
cette personne at elle été appelé par
une autre chaîne
cette chaîne apparemment elle s'appelle
n
le r le j lo 12
mettez tout ça dans l'ordre ça vous fait
nrj12 nrj 12 qui est devenu energy loose
ils ont besoin d'un winner et le winner
c'est lui le petit blond guinée au coeur
chaud et aux pieds froids
merci pour elles je ne sais pas
seule chose que je sais c'est qu'on
l'appelle mister freeze le glaçon priant
est ce que cette personne a été happée
par nrj 12 est ce que cette personne va
partir de des beats est ce que cette
personne veut tout nous dire maintenant
mathieu derrière mots c'est d'aileurs
mou de leurs mots comme vous voulez
quand je veux ce sera mathieu dit alors
de sa merci pour cette séquence
improvisé car mathieu ou savait qu'on
vous aime non franchement on se dit tout
aussi alors si on se dit tout et pour
être très honnête déjà j'étais
extrêmement déjà sûr il a une petite
voix alors vous pouvez enlever la
musique parce que là-bas alors je vais
pas big c c'est n'importe quoi
non je vais parler plus fort et pour
être honnête alors déjà j'ai été très
sensible à ce que vous avez dit que vous
êtes sentie sincère et ça m'a beaucoup
touché que depuis la rentrée que ce soit
vous toute l'équipe wade 8 mais vraiment
je vis des moments formidables
ça sera un discours de départ c'est ça
je remercie la foule world à la lumière
alors oui mais voilà je m'attendais pas
du tout à en parler contrairement à ce
que dit alors je vous donne une partie
de la réponse
la vérité c'est que c'est que c'est une
c'est que oui ils m'ont ils m'ont
rappelé dernièrement et m'ont demandé de
retourner sur la chaîne ça m'a
évidemment beaucoup touché parce que
c'est la chaîne sur laquelle j'ai été
pendant onze jours donné votre temps
voilà ils m'ont donné ma chance j'ai
fait beaucoup de choses beaucoup de
présence et j'aime beaucoup je les
connais tous des cadreurs jusqu'à la
cantine enfin tous tous tous
y'a vraiment benoît et tout le mac quand
je dévoile à prendre un peu l'eau ça me
fait mal c'est sûr donc oui
effectivement il me rappelait ça c'est
vrai en revanche l'info jill malgré tout
ce que tu as dit de manière très gentil
il y en a pas du tout parlé d'argent
était pour nous c'est voilà ça n'a rien
à voir donc oui ça c'est vrai en
revanche pour nous pour l'avenir en
revanche pour l'avenir si vous le voulez
bien
comme je vous aime vraiment sincèrement
et beaucoup et que vous êtes comme un
grand frère je dirais si vous le
permettez
on en parlera à tous les saveurs
voilà tout
je connais ça je voulais toujours tout
dit ça alors non mais moi tu n'as tu en
tout cas quel que soit votre décision
oui je serai toujours mon ami et je vous
soutiendrai dans toutes les décisions
que vous prendrez comme il serait ce
qu'une heure si tu t'en vas
comme vous que vous repartiez sur nrj 12
voilà de toutes les façons on sera là on
sera toujours là pour vous et même aux
mères pleurent et toujours nous dire non
mais vous vous direz on est vraiment on
sera là avec vous et on vous soutiendra
quoi qu'il ya quelqu'un quel que soit
votre décision seraient les seuls à te
regarder
oh